this is the aftermath of fighting
between rival ethnic groups in the
district of chirachampur
dozens have been killed in the violence
since Thursday and many others are
injured near Choi Ching worked as a
nurse and was treating the wounded
after performing her Duty on her way
back home
she seems to encounter the mobs
with
and
she was there at that moment and died
tension between the majority mete and
minority cookie tribal communities has
escalated since February that's when the
state government started a drive to
evict some cookie tribal people from
their houses saying they encroached and
protected forests
it's not a
something that start
in a spiral of a moment this is a
the tribals were long operas like the
dominant committee the military
Community has been in various ways
denying the tribal their rights
under the Constitution as well as those
their development funds that are
entitled for the tribal existing fault
lines have been widened by the coup in
neighboring Myanmar thousands of
refugees sharing ethnic ties with tribal
groups in Manipur have crossed over and
Mayte groups are accusing cookies of
Sheltering illegal immigrants
we are protesting here not to fight with
other communities we want to live in
peace but if people want to dominate us
we will not remain silent the Army has
been deployed to calm the violence
a curfew and a shoot to kill order has
been put in place Barbara angopa Al
Jazeera